[Music]
everybody and welcome to sidetrack your
sci-fi tv and movie channel a bit of a
last second live show here but i wanted
to talk quickly with you guys about a
bunch of rumors and stuff that's been
going around this whole stargate channel
on pluto which doesn't seem to have
happened so really i want to get out
here and ask you
um
a couple of days ago i did a video and
lots of other places did videos and
articles as well about stargate having
its own 24 7 channel on the pluto online
tv
network i've been on today to have a
look it's not there
um and i've actually been accused of um
it being an april fool's joke now if
this was an april fool's joke
it's not a very good one it's actually
really not a funny one at all i don't
know quite where the humor comes from
but also i'm not the only one that fell
for if it was and because it's it was
everywhere gatewall did a video in an
article about it it was on yahoo it was
on giant freaking robot which made me
stop and think maybe i shouldn't have
felt for this um
it was advertised and it was out on lots
and lots of different places
get but please guys you guys are from
all over the world please get into the
comments and tell me has this appeared
this 24 7
channel appeared on pluto in your area
because it hasn't here in the uk
but also i'm going to ask you to do me a
favor please get on the comments
where do you watch stargate in your area
where you're from and let's try and help
each other as a community because i
didn't even realize stargate was back on
sky here in the uk and actually that's
the perfect place for me to watch it i
am a sky subscriber
and it's on the um
catch up so i can watch whatever episode
i want whenever i want much better than
it being on pluto when i have to watch
it when they decide i want to watch it
what are we living in the 2000s i should
be able to watch tv whatever the hell i
like but anyway
so please here guys get in the comments
tell me where you watch stargate let's
help each other so where you're from and
wherever in the world why is scar
stargate available i know in the united
states apparently it's still on netflix
it's on a couple of other places as well
in canada i don't think it's on netflix
but you can correct me here in the uk it
is on sci-fi and it's on sorry
apparently it is on sci-fi channel but
more importantly it's on the sky network
on catch-up and it's also now tv
move on to a couple of other rooms run
around right it was april fool's day
so lots of fun rumors went round
ruben i've got the dvds too mate but
again very 1990s we want a streamer
network right anyway
but yeah the dvds
so a few other um rumors went around
the big stargate one
is is was this channel the 24 7 hour
channel which doesn't seem to have
happened
star trek there's a lot of rumors flying
around one is that alex kirkman as as um
has been sacked or quit
it's not true
in the same article this rumors went
around and these youtube videos went
round
um it also said that um discovery was
being cancelled it's definitely 100 been
and picked up profit season so that's
not true and it also said the picard
series three was being cancelled which
also doesn't make much sense because we
know they just finished filming it
so
if you see these rumors about
picard and all these other things and
and kurtzman getting sacked kurtzman's
unfortunate on a very long contract with
paramount
he's going to be not doing as much start
against our trek over the next couple of
years and he's very much involved in the
man that fell to earth
um remake
um which
is a funny one but that's that's a tv
series i believe that's going on to
paramount plus very shortly the adverts
and stuff bill nye is in it which is
very cool i love donai
um
so so yeah um that's the that's the
rumors of that i again i think a lot of
these were april fool's jokes but some
people i know from seeing comments and
things have taken them very very
seriously
on a very quick stargate front
it never made any sense to me that
target was going on to pluto in the
first place not peacock like i said in
my other video
repeatedly and pluto
it never made any sense to me because
the rumors are now what i've been told
is mgm will be shifting a lot of its old
tv stuff onto
um
amazon
and when i spoke to the mgm guys i speak
to they were actually quite surprised
that this deal had gone through but they
said it must be from before the sale
went through it must be something that's
quite old that's gone through
the long term plan is
that everything will be going on to
amazon
um
but anything that's currently being made
or in the future um mgm are going to be
allowed to create deals with other
people and stuff
um and
then they can you know they could they
can have um i mean it's very common
nowadays particularly movies that
studios don't want to invest all of
their money into a project because then
they lose it all so they will have deals
with other with other um big companies
for example
i've seen a video about mgm making um a
big reboot they want to make they've got
these three big projects they want to
really push forward too quickly james
bond stargate and something else
forbidden planet is the movie they would
love to make now i've had a couple of
comments since saying basically it
doesn't make sense if they don't own it
mgm don't own the rights to forbidden
planet warner brothers do
but a warner brothers mgm co-production
to produce a forbidden planet is
it it's
the way things are done nowadays
so
let's just see
right so dax is saying channel one five
two so is that on
pluto or is that on another channel
um
that would be really great the quality
looks good no commercials have come up
yet again is that on pluto because i
know pluto is very much uh
run by
adverts
like i said i downloaded the pluto app
um i've got it on my tv as well but it's
limited i haven't got as much through my
tv from the sky
and so i got the app online as well and
i've been all the way through it there's
no stargate on it here in the uk
um unless i'm doing something wrong
which again please get into the comments
and explain it so we can all watch it
that's all we want to do
i'm going to watch on the sky anyway
okay guys i just wanted to jump on and
um ask you all to do that please ask you
all to go on and tell everybody that's
watching where do you watch sky where do
you watch target even i will chance guy
um and upshot monique t-shirt game there
you go that's my name t-shirt another
logo
um
uh yeah i tried the app through my phone
that did not work
i hope that a new stargate show will
send secret hideout packaging from
amazon
yeah i do
um i want to see amazon because you know
the amazon did that thing with the
trying to do the drones where they were
going to deliver all the packages to the
drones i would i would love
when they do the new stargate series
just just in the background nothing
nothing to a front but you know like
some amazon packages going through the
games
i think that'd be quite funny um
i think they've got to make they've got
a little tongue-in-cheek with these
things haven't they
and
while i'm on really quickly as well i'll
tell you what we're doing this weekend
um i've got a new video coming out later
today um it is about the x-files so look
forward to that we did the video
yesterday as i said about the mgm
products coming up tomorrow i will be
live with our stormy bear
we're going to be talking about
movies and video games either movies
that get turned into video games or
video games in games that get turned
into movies
and how they're all without question
awful
or are there a couple of
examples to prove the rules sort of
thing
um so join us for that i'm not going to
translate what time it's going to be x
obviously stormy's eight hours behind me
so getting the time that works but it's
either gonna be it's gonna be six or
eight o'clock something like that
and then next week i'm going to be doing
a video with our new mate
and matt who does our discord server if
you go on the facebook channel or the
community page of starbucks you can um
start on stargate sir chartrek you can
see a link to the discord server matt
runs that
he's a massive stargate fan so next week
we're going to be doing a video
right so it looks like it's on in the us
so there we go we're getting a bit of we
get live on air we're getting a bit of
progress so
it looks like it's gone on the us
it's not come on to the uk just yet so
maybe it's just running late
like like amazon packages always do
um
so in that case
it was definitely in the initial report
said it was going to be
uk canada and america
so
that's another thing though picard
series two episodes they're supposed to
be out in the uk on friday they don't
come out until really late on a friday
for some reason i don't know if again if
that's the 12 hours thing but i get up
on a friday morning hoping supercard
next episode and it's never on until
like the evening
i'll have to look at a dpn yeah i'm
gonna have to look again a vpn or a dp
in that case and start getting some
um right now it's timing out apparently
so it looks like they've started to get
the stargate channel but it's look so
this is a bonus looks like it wasn't a
joke it is happening it's just not
happening very well
so um i don't know maybe this is just
glitches and hopefully it'll be on soon
enough right so next week with matt i'm
going to be doing a video um yeah as you
said please get on the discord server
i'm going to do a video with him
we're 99 certain stargates coming back
it's going to be with brad wright
so
please
let's have a chat
about what do we want the stargate
series to look like
what do we want to see
we're going to see general carter by the
sounds of it do we want to see um a
retired general o'neill married to
carter and and so on so on what would we
love the bad guys to be what do we want
all this yeah let's just have a complete
meltdown for a couple of hours and just
talk about stargate the new series
whatever we want to see
that's going to be next week the link
will appear around thursday or friday
and i'm really hoping you guys come to
join us
so thanks for anybody that's popped on i
know it was a very last minute live
video um but
i was getting yelled at for being a for
being an april fool's joke
it wasn't
um so
please go at stargate wherever you watch
it and let everybody else in the
comments know exactly where that is
see you again guys really soon and
good luck i will uh have a lovely
weekend all right see
you